GIFTING HIS SUPPORTERS WITH
MONEY.
PART OF IT IS I THINK STRATEGY
TO GET UNDER TRUMP'S SKIN.
>> ONE PLACE TO WATCH THE
HEARING TODAY WHERE PEOPLE COULD
NOT WATCH IT LAST WEEK WAS ON
FOX NEWS.
THEY AIRED THE HEARINGS LIVE.
>> YES.
>> SOME OF THE COMMENTARY,
THOUGH, THE ANALYSIS AFTERWARD
AND DURING THE INTERMISSION, THE
BREAK, WAS NOT MUCH NEW HERE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF FOX AIRING
IT?
>> WELL, I THINK THEY'RE TRYING
TO STILL DISMISS IT, BUT IT'S
GETTING HARDER, AND I THINK THEY
RECOGNIZE IT'S GETTING HARDER
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, THEY PUT IT
ON NOW TODAY.
THEIR VIEWERS ARE GOING TO SEE
THIS, AND IT'S ALL TRUMP'S
PEOPLE TALKING THIS WAY.
IT'S NOT DEMOCRATS, IT'S NOT THE
HARD LEFT GOING AFTER HIM.
IT'S HIS OWN PEOPLE, AND IT'S
VERY HARD FOR THEM TO DEFLECT
THAT.
AND THEY MAY SAY, OH, THIS HAS
BEEN OUT THERE.
IT'S BEEN OUT THERE, BUT IT
HASN'T BEEN OUT THERE ON THEIR
AIR.
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN COVERING IT.
THEY AREN'T THE ONES WHO HAVE
BEEN OUT THERE SAYING TRUMP WAS
LYING ABOUT EVERY ASPECT OF THIS
BEING A FRAUD, AND NOW THE
AUDIENCE IS HEARING THAT, AND I
THINK THAT COULD HAVE SOME
IMPACT WHERE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
SAYING THERE'S NOT GOING TO BE
ANY MINDS CHANGED, WELL, YOU
HAVE TO SIT THERE AND SAY, GEE,
I HAVE TO BELIEVE THAT EVEN HIS
OWN SUPPORTERS DIDN'T BELIEVE
HIM, YOU KNOW, MAYBE THAT DOES
OPEN UP SOME EYES.
>> WHAT WE SAW THERE, CHRIS
STIREWALT, WHO'S FOX NEWS FORMER
DIGITAL POLITICAL EDITOR WHO
CALLED ARIZONA THAT NIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS TRIED TO
VILIFY THAT MAN.
YOU THINK HE CAN BE EFFECTIVE
WITH THE FOX NEWS AUDIENCE?
>> WELL, LOOK, THIS IS A GUY WHO
WAS EMPLOYED BY FOX NEWS AND HIS
JOB WAS TO CALL VARIOUS STATES.
HE DID HIS JOB.
AND HE CALLED ARIZONA, AND GUESS
WHAT, HE WAS RIGHT.
IT TURNS OUT HE WAS RIGHT, SO
NOW THEY HAVE TO ARGUE, WELL, HE
WAS RIGHT, BUT WE DIDN'T LIKE IT
ANYWAY, AND WE FIRED HIM FOR
THAT.
SO IF YOU'RE IN THE NEWS
BUSINESS AND YOU HAVE A GUY
WHO'S RIGHT AND YOU FIRE HIM FOR
BEING RIGHT, I THINK IT SAYS A
LOT ABOUT YOUR APPROACH TO NEWS,
THAT YOU'RE NOT REALLY
INTERESTED IN THE FACTS, YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN IDEOLOGY OR
PROPAGANDA.
>> YOU THINK THESE SHOULD ALL BE
PRIME TIME, AND WOULD THE
NETWORKS GIVE UP THE AIR TIME
FOR THESE HEARINGS?
>> WELL, THAT'S A REALLY GOOD
QUESTION.
I THINK THEY'RE GREAT COMPELLING
TELEVISION, AND I THINK PEOPLE
WATCHING THEM ARE RIVETED BY IT,
BUT, YOU KNOW, IF YOU'RE IN THE
BUSINESS YOU MIGHT SAY, WELL,
YOU KNOW, WE LOVE IT DURING THE
DAYTIME BUT NOT SO MUCH AT
NIGHT, AND YOU KNOW, THE
WATERGATE HEARINGS WERE FAMOUSLY
IN THE DAYTIME, BUT I THINK
PUTTING HIM IN PRIME TIME IN
SUMMER, IT'S NOT REALLY A BIG
LOSS DURING THAT, AND OBVIOUSLY
IF YOU'RE A NEWS NETWORK LIKE
CNN YOU'RE GOING TO COVER